[Music]
this is what we the players would like
to hear you state and a systemic
oppression of black people silencing our
players from peacefully protesting we as
we've reported that video posted by NFL
players is part of an effort to pressure
the league into doing more to address
racism and inequality as our race for
justice coverage continues we're taking
a deeper look at those issues
Nate Boyer is a former NFL player who
spoke to Colin Kaepernick before his
decision to kneel during the national
anthem four years ago he has also served
as a green beret in the army and he
joins us from Grants Pass Oregon good
morning to you Colin we just saw NFL
players calling on the league to
explicitly call out racism what what
what a given
oh sorry coach Colin Nate my bet to
explicitly call out races I understand
nobody heard my apologies to explicitly
call out racism so far they have
hesitated to use the r-word how do you
think they're gonna respond now I mean
that's a great question I don't I don't
know how they're gonna respond but I've
got a lot of confidence in those guys
ever since you know this started almost
four years ago there's been a lot of
players in the league that are that are
still in the league that have really
sort of taken up the banner and have
continued to speak out and continued to
sort of break it down for a lot of
people you know and make sure that the
narrative stays on point that people
understand you know whether it was Colin
first and then others that came later
that it was never about protesting the
anthem it's not against we're not
protesting against the national anthem
they're protesting during the national
anthem and they're protesting racial and
equality and police brutality and our
system not holding
you know police departments police
officers accountable when things like
this happen
that was why it started and that's got
to continue as far as like that being
the narrative as to why the anthem was
being probed was well why before
protesting during the anthem it's it
important to stay I'm not protesting in
the end it is an important distinction a
very important distinction aiding and
you're great on this subject because you
have a foot in both worlds the world of
football in the world of the military
it's been interesting to watch the NFL
trying to thread the needle here on the
one hand they say they are saddened by
the death of George Floyd and they
support the protest but on the other
hand you think well police brutality was
exactly what Colin Kaepernick was trying
to raise awareness of and yet he's a guy
who is not in the league anymore and
some people point to his protest as a
reason why do you think the criticism of
what Ava Duvernay for example called the
league's disingenuous statement is valid
I mean that's everybody's perception you
know and and she has every right to that
and it's there and they're not in such a
simple spot though as far as you know
when you look at the way a business is
run you know and all the sponsors
involved and stuff like that right
doesn't make it okay I'm just explaining
I think we're a lot of them are coming
from but then also you look at the
intricacy is just within an organization
you know from ownership down to you know
management down to coaching down to the
players there's a lot of different
opinions a lot of different feelings
about things and I think a lot of the
fears and worries from the league from
the organization's is like I don't want
to divide my team I don't want to
ostracize you know a fan base I don't
want to I don't want to divide and you
know I think more and more they're
seeing especially the over this last
week that it doesn't have to be like
that just because you know you're making
a choice to stand by you know certain
players decision to speak out even if
not everybody agrees with their method I
think more and more people are finally
understanding or hopefully if it's done
peacefully and if if everything's
articulated well you know and if it's
led with love you know
that that there's no reason they can't
stand behind that and you know we've
seen players stand behind one another
we've seen even coaches stand behind
that and I think part of that reality is
we gotta get to a place where we've got
you know people of color that are owning
these teams as well and we have more
diversity across the board from you know
the the rookies and oh yeah all the way
up to the top you know it's got to be
more diverse that's an important point
to end on mr. Nate Boyer thank you very
much for your perspective I appreciate
it